at number 7 our urban legend is warning
present pooch
Danijela the voice in the video belongs
to human Omar but Moe over nine million
people have seen this clearly built how
would you like it if someone came to you
and said oh hey you want some ice cream
don't take it when I count to three only
when I say three you can get one two two
and a half five or three although you
wouldn't like jumping to balance your
accounts certainly seems to be good with
numbers
so can jumpy really count in this clip
that looks like jumping those how to
count but that's not really what's
happening the word three is more like a
trigger word for jumping only when I say
three you can get ladies given the
instruction to go for the ball on the
count of three he knows that when he
hears that word three then it doesn't
mean go then it means wait until he next
hears the word three he even knows where
three is likely to fall in a sequence of
numbers five four three so jumpy knew
three is the magic number but can God be
met only good for words they're good
with numbers as well tests have shown
that they reach more or less the level
of a three-year-old been counting it
could be an advantage to realize if your
pups are all where they should be if one
is missing